thank you
[Music]
welcome back to careful boys where we
are currently
off the road whoa we're doing it guys
off of the record off of the record you
want to be racist go ahead you want to
be a bigot get right to it knock
yourself out do it bigotry is my middle
name no that is that the topic today no
the topic today the top five biggest
moments of your life try to think about
this one because there could be
something really major you forgot about
what is the time
that you walked away from a violent
encounter that could have potentially
either hurt you or someone else
what is the time that you walked away
from buying you guys think I'm so
hardcore but I'm really not that
hardcore
you've always walked into it straight up
I walked into the fire not away from it
uh I think I told the story here but
there was a this homeless dude and this
homeless lady fighting across the street
from my house have I told you guys about
that story I don't know I don't remember
that and um I thought the guy was gonna
like beat the [ __ ] out of her so I was
like I was across the street and I was
trying to be they're probably like where
that doorway is
and I'm like hey you know that's really
far you guys gotta you guys gotta stop
let's say it right and then the guy was
like call the cops man she's gonna be my
[ __ ] ass and I was like
oh
wait I don't want to call the cops with
the girls beating the guys out the guy
they were like fighting and he was like
she was shoving them girl fist fighting
yeah and the guy was just like he was he
was being more defensive but I was like
man I was worried that like he was gonna
punch her in the [ __ ] head or
something and I was gonna be there
standing like watching how come you
didn't want to call the cops well it's a
lot of work yeah dude you got a car yeah
bro I don't like talking to people on
the phone bro I don't like doing all
that you know yeah I get I get anxiety I
get anxiety from talking to people on
the phone so what do I do I go across
the street and I'm like hey uh you guys
gotta stop because if I call the cops
you know you guys are gonna get in
trouble and send me a whole [ __ ]
thing man yeah I won't do that I gotta
go to work in an hour bro I can't I
can't do this [ __ ] I'm stopping home for
lunch and I gotta start cooking so eat
your cold watermelon you know I mean no
that's for later bro like every night
yeah you [ __ ] idiot dude yeah so so
that so they start fighting and [ __ ] and
then she's like spitting on him she's
ripping this [ __ ] shirt and I'm like
hey guys can you please stop like please
stop and then pretty much you know
the more cussing more shoving and
eventually they left but then I crossed
the street went back to my house and I
thought I was like I was probably dumb I
probably shouldn't have done that I like
inserted myself in there but in my head
I like to think I saved both of them but
then you didn't walk away though that's
I did it opposite of what nah but I
still I kept my that's opposite I kept
my distance you know what I mean I just
was like hey you guys gotta stop you
guys got to stop wow yeah so they
continue they continued the violence no
they stopped they stopped oh they did
they stopped and they walked away so you
made the world a little bit peaceful a
little bit better I'm I'm a real
Peacemaker bro but that was the only
that's the only [ __ ] time that I
could think of I was taking Nikki to
this party it was it was like
downtownish right and we were trying to
find where the [ __ ] it is because you
know downtown is like such a nightmare
especially in like one of these places
where it's like some company rented out
this like place and like yeah we all
know where it is but nobody knows where
the [ __ ] it is it's an industrial
Warehouse yeah exactly so nobody knows
where the [ __ ] it is so it's like
probably 11 o'clock 11 130 through these
do so we're walking down the street
trying to find this like where this
Warehouse is they're these two dudes and
they're [ __ ] drunk as [ __ ] and
they're just yelling [ __ ] non-stop
yelling [ __ ] I'm holding Nikki I can
feel her like a little like tensing up
yeah a little bit nervous
and so to these guys I'm just like yo
shut the [ __ ] up
and then they immediately turn and
they're like hey don't get knocked out
don't get knocked out bro bro bro bro
don't get no job bro bro bro bro
and then he's like what the [ __ ] Steve
no please and I'm like I'm like what
what are they gonna do they're so
[ __ ] drunk they can't even run at me
right now they trip over their own shoes
um but basically like you know Nikki was
even more scared she's like you know you
in a situation where the uh which is
fair I understand so then I I was like
okay fine and so I just walked her away
into my car and then we got the [ __ ] out
of there well these guys are like like
one of them like was like throwing a
shoe at me like on the way out of there
and they're like flipping me off well if
they're throwing a shoe they haven't you
have nothing to worry about I wasn't
worried about them anyway but that's the
point is that you know I guess I walked
away but I was just it was not a
threatening situation to me but they put
to Nikki she's like holy [ __ ] this is
crazy I can't remember once uh this was
I think maybe just six months ago
I was in Houston with Nadine
and we were uh we're watching the UFC
fight at like a bar I really wanted it
was like a big one that was going on and
so um we we got he got alcoholic drinks
I got non-alcoholic drinks because you
guys know myself
I'm crazy I'll take a black coffee and
then it was it was one of those really
cool places where they got like a big
old screen in the back and they got
those cool little lights those little
like tungsten whatever was it 4 45 in
the afternoon no no this is late this is
like probably like eight pm oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
man sports like looking at us watch the
whole game racing the sunrise there yeah
I'm gonna have to go to bed pretty soon
we're sitting there watch the UFC fight
and then you know me how like I just
pound non-alcoholic drinks like crazy
because the water's deep so I put I put
like four like not unsweetened iced teas
down and then I went to the bathroom
when I went to the bathroom obviously it
was drunk people and stuff this guy as
as I was coming in he comes up to me
he's like oh like
like all drunk like breathing and he
bumps me in the shoulder and he walks
away and uh it was crazy because like
when I was in college I was looking for
events like disrespect yeah I was like
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] time
[ __ ] you're searching for it
yeah but after you did that I was just
like oh [ __ ] like who Am I who am I and
I just went to go pee and when I went to
go pee I was like
dude I'm [ __ ] proud of myself I'm not
I'm not the same person so as soon as I
came out you didn't feel hurt like a
little bit of ego hurt like I needed to
kill there wasn't a bird on the shoulder
here it'd be like you're a little [ __ ]
boy yeah and he's like a little little
tissue paper in his nose oh my God no I
was just like that was like a shame Ted
Joe that was sitting there as well she's
laughing at Bart
nobody can see you you could just jack
off
[Laughter]
everybody that's long hair Joe you got
the corner urinal this is the best place
to jack off I've done it here twice
already yeah and I was just like I think
you're squeezing after you pee and I was
like damn that's that's crazy because I
remember even like in that early college
like high school era
where when something like that happens
kind of like the the physiological
effects of what you feel like oh [ __ ]
I'm not [ __ ] alive this is the [ __ ] I
was [ __ ] born to do you feel
Goosebumps and it's almost like you won
the lottery and then for for none of
that to happen and just go oh [ __ ] oh my
bad and then just kind of like
take like the mature route and like none
of it has to ever even go there I texted
you I was like oh my God you won't
believe what just happens dude [ __ ]
shoulder check me and I'm just gonna go
sit down and enjoy the the fights on TV
nothing happens it feels like cool I'll
see you in 15 minutes
did you like have afterthoughts do you
have like flashes like while you were
watching the [ __ ] fight on TV did you
start like having little mini flashes
that in your subconscious where you're
like I could [ __ ] do that to that guy
I can [ __ ] choke hold this
[ __ ] no none of it wow I'm so
proud of you I just actually hey what
about this honest honest question what
if you bumped into Geo oh dude that's
different you would [ __ ] him up huh
she's a gangster what does Bart do
[ __ ] jump on his shoulders and rip
his ears off and that's fine that's fine
bro Donkey Kong on Mortal Kombat oh yeah
dude you got a good vertical height oh I
got one actually go ahead it better
actually be the [ __ ] real thing it's
like it's another homeless guy watch nah
this is like across the street we played
no watermelon he's like I'm further away
I have a mega folks he's on the 710
North I call them I say hey you guys
better stop I was in a bat it was like a
it was like a adult league basketball
game and one of my teammates he was a
little hothead he would like pick fights
with everybody and stuff so he's picking
a fight with his one guy is it Jason
Chen no no no this is he's actually
three Jason Chen's that's how tall he
was oh [ __ ]
um and he was picking a fight
with this other guy on the team so I
went in tried to break it up I was like
no no I'm trying to pull my guy away and
then the other team his guy comes up to
me he's like this short little [ __ ]
little stubby little Mexican dude he
comes up to me and I didn't even see him
he comes from the side grabs him by my
neck and then like shoves me and he like
gets in my face trying to fight me when
you have nothing to do with it bro I
wasn't trying to break up the fight oh
[ __ ] you know damn and then he he tries
to get in my face he's like let's [ __ ]
he's like in my face like let's [ __ ]
fight right now [ __ ] you up
and then in my head I just was like like
just relax like be cool and then I just
told him I was like all right if you
want to fight we can fight after the
game that's all I said and we still had
like another quarter like half a quarter
if you ever get into fight you gotta
text anyone come watch I'm not dude
there was no guarantee you want to fight
hold on one second hey Bart how long
will it take you to get here just turn
your IG light off but it's like I'm
coming from Vegas right now or it's like
I'm going to bed at 15 minutes I've seen
Nick tee off on [ __ ]
like [ __ ] like Roy Jones Jr [ __ ]
boom boom Miss Boom Boom Boom like that
kind of [ __ ] she's full of [ __ ] yeah
I've seen him I've seen him take away
the confidence of six-foot guys [ __ ]
beautiful because they come in confident
right and then you can see them like
just giving up Steve's confident over
six feet can can you show us nah dude
I'll probably suck that dude nickel get
down on his knees and start opening his
mouth get it back no but it's it's a
it's a beauty to watch him it's [ __ ]
race sick now so he he's getting in my
face and I'm like all right if you want
to fight we can fight after the game
because I knew he was gonna [ __ ] out
because because it's like it's like the
heat of them once you think about it a
little yeah people puff up their chances
like I'm I was the smallest guy in the
court for sure and this is probably when
I was like 22 so I was like even smaller
than I am now the matter of fact thing
is pretty good too like if you want to
fight we do it after the game all right
I was pretty [ __ ] mad I was I was
like fired up I was like oh okay you
want to fight like you want to be a
tough guy obviously I'm like trying to
be cool and stuff in my head but uh and
then the game ends we finish
and then I'm like where you at Doc I
probably shouldn't have even done this
again I think you're not doing the Walk
Away part of the story but I like this
no no but but he was and then he was
like running out he just left he just
left because he [ __ ] and then ever
since then he saw you he saw me he saw
you do this I was like where you at
where you at and would you have fun if
he was like right here Nick I don't know
maybe maybe at that age I didn't know
you're gonna say Nick for some reason
even though that's his name but good
good call he left and then afterwards
every time we played him again in that
League he was like really nice to me so
oh hey you yeah you well you made him
respect you yeah so you used verbal Jiu
Jitsu you did like an alpha dog move
basically
I was scared I was scared I win like
guys like that
um puff their chest at you and if you
give them weakness like if you at least
if you if you actually tried a reason to
go dude I'm not trying to fight and
immediately when they know that they try
to punk you harder because they know
you're not gonna fight back which
I was trying to be a nice person and
you're taking that Advantage now I have
to fight you and then they turn it
around again like I'm gonna [ __ ] call
the cops it's like you're the [ __ ]
bully here what are you doing yeah
people are wild dude yeah people get
people get wild especially in like sport
atmospheres like that like you see I see
so many people getting fights on
basketball courts way like so much
happens all the time that's why I
stopped playing basketball people try to
[ __ ] fight you all the time I had a
proud walk away moment in a basketball
uh we were actually playing at this
church that we used to always play at
and I think I was going up for like a
layup or something and this dude he uh
back elbowed me like like through like
that because you I don't know he was
just very aggressive and then so I went
up hit my face fell to the ground and I
got up and then like Dave is like you're
bleeding and I was like oh [ __ ] and then
like in the Heat of the Moment you know
all I'm trying to do is like go and like
wash up and stuff and then like I was
like wait this guy didn't apologize he's
still playing aggressively I think I
should have put him in his place but
before I knew it he was already walking
on the other side of the gate walking
away
do you remember this but you know how we
used to always play games like that
right yeah we're just strangers and
stuff yeah and then someone said to me I
thought you were gonna [ __ ] him up and I
was like oh that hurt my ego a little
bit maybe I should chase after him and
[ __ ] [ __ ] him up now because maybe I
should have done something but it was it
just all happened so fast
but in my head I was like also that's a
accident and and we're always playing at
the at the basketball courts there if if
we ruin it I ruin it for everybody yeah
but that's when my I knew I changed
because I was like
oh I don't have to
um find this guy and I don't obsess over
thinking about like like having to get
any revenge like like because I'm hurt
you know yeah
the the guy that I was like oh [ __ ] I
think Joe really changed was uh the dude
at JJ's
what happened what happened oh you were
there I told him to shut the [ __ ] up and
I pushed him and I walked away at the
restaurant Joe was like straight up like
this in the middle yeah yeah
like twice she's like get away from he's
like in your space though he's a linger
I like Joe that'll whoop his ass right
there and he was one of those guys where
like sometimes you'll talk to somebody I
like my personal space when I have a
conversation somebody especially with
somebody I'm not that close yeah like so
you start talking you start scooting
away and then you don't get the hand
they go oh okay and then they scoot away
and they go oh yeah yeah hold on and
they start talking a little closer he
was one of those [ __ ] guys yeah
because I had a flashback of like
wanting to actually like do this grab
him bring him outside and just [ __ ]
repeatedly slap him and I was like just
slaps
wrestling style wrestling style
wrestling Style
but it it went away in a Flash and I was
able to laugh at it and then while I'm
driving you know home I was I was
basically telling my friend like check
your friend dude he's [ __ ] stupid
he's gonna get his ass kicked one day
yeah and he goes oh I'm sorry we all
know this but there's just something off
with them so I was like okay he's lucky
that you were that nice man that's
[ __ ] weird I think also because I
knew his friend I gave him that little
bit of like yeah you know we have a
mutual friend so but dude what the hell
right like that was one of the weirdest
and it's very loud so it's like it was
so weird what's wrong with you man yeah
but um he's shoving his phone in your
face
hey look at this look at this look look
violating that personal space talk to my
friend like [ __ ] remember this guy and
you're like no I don't know who the [ __ ]
that is
Anthony do you have any stories I feel
like no no violence comes near your way
yeah you're with your Wiggly boy that's
what I mean I feel like it every anyone
around Anthony either has a bone or a
wet [ __ ] sex house those are your only
options yeah yeah this is your only uh
there was a there was a time where uh we
had a Quest Crew gig in Chicago and then
you walked away and the person died
no we were just uh so we walked into
this like bar it was like before the
show and we walked into this bar at
night where like the student you know
when you go to a place where the
students are listening they go oh come
to this cool bar we'll take you oh yeah
and it's just like okay cool bar or
whatever and then um we'd go in there
and then I guess because so many like
it's like the Asian
Association of that college usually will
have you so you all go out and it just
looks like a shitload of Asians and then
we go into this bar and then these like
two guys lock up like right when I
walked in these two dudes went up and
they were like how the [ __ ] just so many
of you just come in here right now like
they're like how'd you guys repopulate
so [ __ ] fast and I was like not bad
I'm just kind of like stunned I'm like
what is this this guy's like intro to be
like I'm just playing but like it never
came like he just kept saying more [ __ ]
was he Asian as well no he was he was
too it was a black dude and a white dude
so it was pretty funny and then um tag
team Race and I was just a little bit
like I wasn't I was mad at first and
then I started to understand like
what the [ __ ] because he starts going
yeah we really [ __ ] bombed the [ __ ]
out of you guys back there didn't we no
he's like what are you doing wait was
this like a part of like Steve's family
was his grandpa
that's why I freaked out I was like is
this my grandfather I was like he went
to a lot of ours this guy looked they
were like younger than me and I was like
let's stick up Japanese
because they started saying these
[ __ ] crazy you think they were just
trying to get into a fight yeah my
friends absolutely they would do that
all the time and just say the wildest
[ __ ] so they could get into fist fight
yeah and they they did bomb the [ __ ] out
of you guys they're like why the [ __ ]
they're like why the [ __ ] so many
[ __ ] Japs here all of a sudden like
none of us are Japanese caps who says
that anymore
oh yeah but he don't think he was there
but he starts speaking this British
accent whoa what the [ __ ] yeah it was
just like it was super strange because
like I expected to be mad but I was more
like confused you were shocked where was
this at Chicago you usually don't get
mad till like after the incident and you
actually think about it you're like okay
I'm also really good at weighing cost
yeah and to me like I have a I have a
special like personal rule I don't know
when I made this up but if if a guy's
trying to fight with me and I don't
think he's better looking with than me I
don't think it's a fair fight
because I don't think it's even you're
never gonna have a fair fight you sexy
[ __ ] I don't think he's all like he's
not as pretty I'm a much sexier man
we're not putting the same amount of
money on the table then because this
guy's gonna look like [ __ ] after a
pounding I can lose you know I don't
know something nice
I'm like that's not fair you know but if
it's a guy that's prettier than me then
like I could actually you know win a
pretty good pot so in red that's what
I'm saying dude create it I'm sexy and I
know it it was actually about you
it was actually about Ryan or if it's a
guy who's not that good looking you
could make him look better like
potentially corrective corrective
surgery free plastic surgery cosmetic
assault is what we call it
yeah so then I I just wasn't motivated
to fight because they were both like you
know pretty you know they weren't no
attractive guys yeah and they were dumb
so I'm like I don't think this is like I
don't want to know that like I broke my
nose or something over like a random ass
fight that I have no like there's no
what is it called I have no interest in
it yeah yeah as a kid I felt like you
had so much to prove and then as I get
older I'm like I don't give a [ __ ] yeah
it's like if you got a fight with this
guy like that's not a good story or even
if a guy that came up to me says all
kinds of [ __ ] racist [ __ ] and like
let's say [ __ ] peed on my car or
whatever I'm just like you know I'll
just go to the car wash like I don't
know like even if he [ __ ] on my leg
I'm like I'll just watch take a shower
just letting him do each of these things
in a row yeah it's just so this is the
line you guys
we're gonna test it later too earlier
he's like yeah I did a men's health
shoot and they were sticking fingers up
my ass and [ __ ] but I guess it's part of
how you get like the best camera shot I
don't know and I didn't get paid
so
years ago right I had an encounter
um right in front of barbell uh I was
parked in my car I just finished working
out and then I was just like fiddling
with my phone thank God my car was
locked because I heard my door like
trying to like someone was trying to
open it so I looked and it was this guy
and I thought he was just like trying to
talk to me or whatever but then he
looked directly in my eye and it was
bloodshot red like and he was a cholo
bald head [ __ ] like gangstered out
and I was like holy [ __ ] right so I
turned on my car and I pulled out and I
drove up because I was like what the
[ __ ] is happening right and then I
pulled down my window and I was like
what are you doing and he goes [ __ ] you
I'll [ __ ] kill you and I was like oh
[ __ ] so I boned out for a little bit but
I was like you're a [ __ ] dude exactly I
ran away from a violent situation but
then I was like what if he goes in
barbell like I don't know like so let me
see what he does skinny people in
barbell nowadays you know what I mean
it's like so I busted at you and then I
wanted to like follow him in a distance
so I was just driving up to see what he
was doing and he was actually harassing
two members oh no so two guys they
weren't one of the buff guys they're
like one of the guys I just started
right and they were standing there
looking scared so I was when I drove up
I was like hey [ __ ] you right and then
because I want him to come to me yeah
and then so I drove up a little bit
because he turned around and he started
chasing so I drove up a little bit and I
said yeah yeah [ __ ] you and I drove up a
little bit and then he kept chasing me
like an idiot right and then the other
guys yeah basically and then the other
guys were able to like run away so I
boned out and then uh I came back again
to see if he was still there I parked my
car went inside and then I was telling
everybody
um and I guess like the the the members
either went back or someone talked to
him one of the employees talked to them
and said is everything okay we had to
call the cops apparently they're just
like yeah that guy was just trying to
fight us like find a reason to fight he
smelled like alcohol he was like
deranged yeah and then so that kind of
[ __ ] was like
you know I could have been this big dude
like let's get out of the car and like
duke it out like men but I'm like that
guy was insane and that [ __ ] was scary
dude or something yeah I don't know like
that was some scary [ __ ] but I was like
I guess I kind of ran from that
situation you did you tucked your tail
between your legs
you came back and you drew the yeah you
baited his ass off and you saved me a
Nick you big man your big boy I know
like I'm protected in my car and [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] dude
[Music]